estas votaciones se celebran bajo un
clima de profunda crisis económica de
años y en paz político ya que en beirut
bajo la sombra de la tragedia del puerto
de beirut en agosto 2020 que devastó
media ciudad el panorama no da muchas
esperanzas a un cambio líbano tiene un
sistema confesional político y cada
secta tiene una cuota de poder sin
embargo en estas elecciones han
participado candidatos independientes no
sectarios salidos de la sociedad civil
del descontento de las manifestaciones
de 2019 que compiten con los partidos
tradicionales pero cuando el 80% de la
población libanesa vive bajo el umbral
de la pobreza y tiene escasez de
gasolina electricidad y medicamentos la
gente suele tender a acercarse a los
políticos tradicionales
quizás el mayor desafío de estas
elecciones es qué pasará con la
comunidad suní después de que hariri se
haya retirado de la vida política ya que
está dividida desde su partido el
movimiento futuro se ha llamado al
boicot de las elecciones pero hay
candidatos suníes si están participando
por temor a que un vacío de poder subir
pueda dar ventaja a su principal rival
el partido hizbollah que es chilling